CERN's this morning about the growing
impact of the corona virus in Africa
South Africa is a continents hardest hit
country with more than 1300 cases there
Debora patta visited one of the nation's
poorest communities the township of
Alexandra in Johannesburg South Africa
has some of the toughest lockdown
regulations in the world but enforcing
them is not so easy here in a low-income
inner-city area security forces fire
rubber bullets at those defying orders
to stay at home shot after shot is fired
as police clear the streets
the parks anyway people are gathered
illegally security forces are taking
their chances in South Africa alcohol is
banned this place is suspected of
selling it they're cracking down and the
stay-at-home order has once again laid
bare the enduring fault lines in South
Africa of poverty and race in places
like Alexandra Township alone policeman
struggles to control a crowd
eventually the military was brought in
to assist that did not end well security
forces have been filmed humiliating
transgressors by making them do
demeaning physical exercises people line
up to buy food observing little of the
social distancing protocols now in place
standing in the cubes that's the thing
it hasn't hit us because it hasn't
happened it's not so close to home but
she's wrong the worst fears of
authorities have already been realized
there is at least one confirmed case of
covert 19 in Alexandra at least 10,000
field workers have been deployed around
the country to test for the disease
authorities are terrified that if the
virus is not
contained it could exact a far higher
death toll than anywhere else in the
world for CBS this morning Debora patta
Alexandra Township Johannesburg South
Africa